Do you spend more money
on virtual fashion in video games
than you do on physical clothes?
About a third of all teenage
gamers in America do.
Do you think the government
is actually run by a secret cabal
of demon-worshiping perverts?
About 50 million people do.
(Laughter)
These numbers sound crazy to you?
It's because they are,
but they're also a sign of things to come.
The world feels like a pretty
insane place right now.
And if you spend any time
on the internet at all,
you can probably tell that people think
it's going to get a lot worse.
Now, that may be the case,
but this feeling is why I believe
that we're going to see
a rise in social unrest
in the coming decades,
and that is going to come
from a surprising place.
Video games.
Now before you think,
"Is this going to be another talk
linking video game to violence?"
Sorry to disappoint you,
that’s been proven conclusively wrong,
and that is really old thinking.
But what I am going to argue
is that video games are going to become
the platform through which
tomorrow's social battles will be fought
and the source of recruitment
for some of the strangest
and possibly most impactful
social movements of the future.
I like to call these video gamecults.
Sounds kind of scary, I admit,
but I hope to show
how they might also be used
as a tool to cause some serious hope.
Now this is all just my personal opinion.
But I started thinking
about this a few years ago
after I heard a very interesting story
while working in the Gulf.
The story was about Hassan ibn Sabbah,
a charismatic young preacher
who lived about 1,000 years ago
in an age full of drama,
conflict and social change.
Hassan became famous for creating
the Order of Assassins:
a fanatically devoted group of young men
known as the fedayeen,
"those who sacrifice themselves."
His men were so devoted to him
that, the legend goes,
they would throw themselves
from the rafters to their death
at his command.
Actually, this is where we get
the expression "a leap of faith" from.
So this got me thinking.
Why would someone do this?
What could convince someone
so fervently to believe in something
that they would welcome their own death?
The answer is 11th century
virtual reality.
See, Hassan had cultivated a myth
that he could send people to heaven
and bring them back again
without actually having to die.
And of course, he didn't
actually have this power,
but before a mission, the story goes,
he would dose his soldiers
with massive amounts of hash.
(Laughter)
Their enemies actually called them
the "ḥashshāshīn,"
which is also where we get
the word "assassin" from.
This would knock them out
and then he would lower them down
into a secret garden he had built
behind his mountain fortress,
designed to look exactly
like a replica of heaven.
Waking up in this simulated paradise,
his men would gorge themselves
on all the things
they had been denied in life.
Then, after a night of ecstasy,
they would awaken back in their barracks,
convinced of Hassan's powers,
eager to fulfill his suicide missions
in order to return to heaven again.
So.
What does this have to do with today?
Well, most scholars agree
that this is probably just a myth,
but that's not the point.
The point is that people
believed deeply in Hassan
and his vision for the world
and were willing to sacrifice
their lives for it.
He gave them a sense
of meaning and purpose
during a time of great uncertainty.
A purpose which he communicated
using the best tools of his day.
And that is what brings us to video games.
Video games are already the world's
dominant form of entertainment.
They're three times larger
than the entire global film
and music industries combined.
Every year,
the top streamers on Twitch
receive on average twice as many views
as the biggest Hollywood movies.
And collectively,
we spend twice as much time
watching and playing video games
as we do using all other forms
of social media combined.
That's a lot of eyeballs.
Game sales are huge,
but the real action
is in in-game economies
where people spend
over 130 billion dollars a year
buying and selling virtual goods online.
Everything from outfits to avatars,
to vehicles to weapons,
to dances to architecture to music,
to access to live events and more.
Haven't even mentioned NFT or Web3,
but these hopefully
will become the infrastructure
that drives this going forward.
So if you're wondering
what the metaverse looks like,
this is it.
The reason games are so successful
is because they provide
a deep sense of engagement,
community and purpose.
Yes, we use them to escape
and to entertain, and that’s OK.
But at their best,
they speak to some of our primal
social and psychological needs,
from feeling effective
to achieving our goals,
to belonging to a group,
to working for something
bigger than yourself.
Describing his experience
in a top World of Warcraft guild,
the player Wincy once wrote,
"It felt so amazing...
Thinking back, it was probably
the most intense,
positive emotional experience of my life.
Not my kid being born,
not getting married."
(Laughter)
"My mind was convinced we were in a war
against an insurmountable foe
and we won."
You can probably see
where I'm going with this.
Although he later went on to regret
the amount of time he spent online,
gamers develop a deep sense of commitment
to a shared narrative world.
A world which provides for them
in a way that "real-world" jobs
and relationships often do not.
And this is already the world
that our children live in.
The only thing that my son and daughter
want for their birthdays
are Skyblock coins and digital emotes
for their characters.
Most of their social time
outside of school
is spent hanging out in-game
with their friends.
My son Teo, he's already
flipping NFTs to, in his words,
get rich as quickly as possible
so he can take care of us
when the world falls apart.
Thanks Teo, appreciate that.
That's why I think games
are going to be one of the driving forces
of tomorrow's culture.
But if that's the game's part,
what about the cults part?
Well, I'm sure we can all agree
that the coming years are going to be
interesting, to say the least.
From climate change, mass migration,
pandemics, job loss
and now war.
The future feels terrifying
for many people.
And this is having a tremendous impact
on our mental health.
One third of all
US undergraduates surveyed
report having moderate to severe anxiety.
Their rates of suicidal thinking
and severe depression
doubled over the last decade or so.
And COVID didn't help.
But it's not just the US, either.
Two thirds of those surveyed
in a study of 17 different countries
reported that they thought their children
were going to grow up poorer
and not have successful careers.
In other words,
the world feels like it's falling apart
for a lot of people.
And when worlds fall apart,
people start looking for answers
wherever they can find them.
And charismatic leaders like Hassan
have always been happy to provide them.
And their actions have shaped
the course of history.
From the Protestant Reformation
in the 16th century
to the rise of new religious movements
in the 19th century,
every era of social change historically
has been followed by a wave
of new believers and fanatical behavior.
QAnon is just the most recent example.
And while each generation's
cults look different
and the definition of a cult
is certainly up for debate,
they do share general characteristics.
The first is that they inspire
a sense of higher purpose,
often through a lens of good versus evil,
where you are the hero,
that creates a sense of passion
or commitment that seems insane
or irrational to the outsider.
And the second is
that they adopt the form of
and use the tools of the dominant
organizations of their day.
From the church
to the corporation
to the social media network
to our subject for today, the metaverse.
So what happens when you mix
billions of people looking for meaning,
safety and security
with widespread virtual worlds,
crypto economies and gaming culture?
The answer, I believe, is “gamecults.”
Large-scale social movements
powered by extreme or bizarre beliefs,
birthed in virtual worlds,
driven by game dynamics,
but with real-world consequence.
The future is about to get weird.
We can already see examples
of this all around us.
We just haven't had a name for it yet.
Softer versions look like BTS stans
swarming Donald Trump rallies online,
but more extreme versions look like
Hezbollah's own custom-made video game
called Special Forces,
designed to recruit young people
and train them to kill their enemies.
White nationalist groups are hosting
Call of Duty tournaments online
to attract followers,
and there are Roblox games
where you can drive your car
through Black Lives Matter protesters
or assume the role of Kyle Rittenhouse
and shoot anti-fascist protesters.
And there are many other examples,
but all of them are wrapped
in a layer of Discord servers
and YouTube channels and podcasts
that act as the funnel to draw you
deeper into a web of extremism
and radical behavior.
What starts on the screen
no longer stays on the screen.
QAnon is a perfect example of this.
What started on 4chan and Facebook,
mutated into a live-action
role-playing group
for evangelical militants
and ended up as
an anti-vaccination campaign.
Before you know it,
we have a million excess deaths
from COVID in the United States
and a political landscape far stranger
than anything we've ever seen.
The same is going to be true for games.
First you're a player,
then you're a fan,
soon you're in a clan,
and before you know it,
you're invading the Capitol.
So I'm a futurist.
And there's a saying with futurists,
that your job is not to just
predict the automobile,
but to predict the traffic jams.
So what might this look like
in 10 or 20 years,
when widespread augmented
and virtual reality
meets thriving crypto economies
and a generalized crisis of meaning?
Well in the future,
games are going to be everywhere.
They're going to move from our screens
and onto the streets around us.
Hundreds of millions,
if not billions of people
will be buying, selling, making
and trading virtual goods online.
They're going to assume
roles as characters,
follow quests and get real-world money
for in-game performance.
Guilds, corporations and clans
will form around them.
They might start offering
salaries, paying benefits,
and providing real-world services like
education or health care or even security.
People's entire lives will be built
around their characters and their stories,
particularly if things get really bad.
And those stories will come to dominate
popular culture and politics.
Now, thankfully,
not all of them will be harmful,
but some will be violently
evangelical in their nature.
It's got me thinking,
there must be a better way
that we can use these dynamics
to heal instead of harm.
So I started thinking,
what might this look like?
How can we explore possible futures
for positive gamecults?
So here are just three examples
I came up with a few friends.
Consider Druidica,
a Minecraft-like nature game
designed to restore damaged ecosystems
and preserve indigenous knowledge.
Or perhaps Walkabout,
a Rust-like survival game for refugees
designed to encourage skill sharing,
interdependence and mutual aid
linked to scriptural messages
of tolerance and compassion.
Or perhaps Temple, a pray-to-earn game,
linked to a network
of nondenominational meditation spaces
where players can perform
coordinated acts of care
to level up on the good works board.
A kind of, decentralized
church of kindness,
powered maybe by HOLY coin.
It's clear that something
like this is coming.
The question is:
What can we do about it now?
As we've learned from social media,
technological fixes and regulatory
restrictions will only go so far.
And in the attention economy
of political priorities,
gamecults are clearly quite low.
But that’s OK,
it means we still have time
to do something about them.
That's why I think that everyone,
from policymakers to players
to game designers and gamers
should be having a conversation
about what this means right now.
If you are a media company,
you should be talking
to experts in radicalization.
If you are a game company,
you should be speaking to those
who don't understand gaming dynamics
and the communities around them.
If you're a church
or a religious institution,
you should be understanding how people
use these tools to build beliefs
and what they're believing.
And finally, perhaps most importantly,
if you're a parent,
you should be playing games with your kids
to understand the world
that they're growing up in
and to have a conversation with them
about the role that they might play in it.
Someone's going to connect these dots.
The question is:
Who is going to be our modern-day Hassan?
And will the games of tomorrow
be games of subjugation and domination?
Or inspiration and liberation.
It's really up to us.
Thank you.
(Applause)